- So wait Tim, where are you calling from?
- I'm in, I'm in New York,
we're doing some press up here
and I'm actually getting to see
a couple of our daughters who live here.
So we're getting to hang out
with them for a little bit.
- Oh, that's exciting.
Are they in school up there
or are they just living up
there? What are they doing?
- Both of them are actors.
So they're there in New York
pursuing that, that job.
- Okay. Last time I saw you,
you were here and one of
them was still in school
and I was like, all right.
And you were like,
I don't know if she's
going to leave school.
- All grown up now,
they're out on their own.
So we're empty-nesters but it's, it's,
it's a blessing and a curse
at the same time, I guess.
So, you know, you miss them
and you miss the energy
and you miss them being
around, around the house,
and all their friends,
and all the stuff that
comes along with that.
But it's also nice for mom and dad
to have the house to themselves
every now and then to.
- Hell yeah. Bring that fire back.
What!
Well, well, Tim in 1883,
Faith plays your wife,
so that must've been a stretch
and Isabel plays your daughter.
Does she fit in, right,
right in with your family?
I feel like literally
I'm looking at a girl
that could have come from y'all, so.
- When we first saw Izzy,
when we walked, the
first day at cowboy camp,
we walked in.
I mean, of course she's,
she's just beautiful and sweet,
and so poised and so mature.
But when we first saw
her, we went right away,
right away, we thought, my gosh, she, she,
she looks like she could be our daughter.
I mean, it was this perfect casting.
And, and,
and then the more we got to know her,
the sweeter she got and the
more we grew to love her
and respected her.
And, and she, she's just a, she's a,
she's incredible,
she just shines in the show and,
and anybody who knows her
and it was around her on set,
knows that she shines in person as well,
and in real life.
- I miss you Tim.
- That's so sweet.